.
Alexander ist
in seinem Diplomaten-Auslandpraktikum
unterwegs in Myanmar.
Das ist eigentlich die Hauptstadt,
Naypyidaw.
Und das ist eigentlich
das Botschaftsviertel. Ziemlich leer.
Ja, das wäre jetzt der Ort, wo
die zukünftige Schweizer Botschaft
stehen müsste, sollte, würde.
Also das ist jetzt
für die Schweiz reserviert?
Das muss man sich so vorstellen,
dass da, wo das hohe Gras ist,
mal die Schweizer Botschaft steht.
Strom und Strasse
wären seit 15 Jahren bereit.
* Anschwellende Streicherklänge *
Hold on!
Are you at the Swissclub?
Esta es mi machete,
Spickzettel auf Deutsch.
Du bist Krisenmanager.
Yes, are you here?
Yallah, yallah.
(Mann) Diplomatie ist in der Schweiz
nicht sonderlich beliebt.
Man kennt uns wenig -
vielleicht ist das unsere Schuld.
A toast together!
Auf Sie zählen wir
für die nächsten Jahrzehnte.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Schnell gezupfte Gitarrenklänge *
Am Flughafen in Buenos Aires:
Jonas ist seit vier Wochen hier
und macht seine Diplomatenausbildung.
Heute kommt
endlich auch seine Familie an.
Ich freue mich sehr, gleich
Celestine und Katrin zu sehen.
Sie kommen gleich hier raus.
Oh, hallo!
Hallo!
Hallo, Schätzchen!
Hoi, Celestine, hallo.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Darf ich sie herausnehmen?
Ei, ei, ei, ei, ei.
Grosses Mädchen, grosses Mädchen!
Oh! Papa, genau.
Jetzt sind wir bei Papa.
* Schnelle,
klassische Gitarrenklänge *
Der Fahrer
des Botschafters höchstpersönlich
bringt die Familie
in die neue Wohnung.
Hier sieht's ja aus wie im Hotel.
- Ja, ja. Geht rein!
Wow!
- Buenos Dias. - Buenos Dias.
Erst gestern
hat Jonas den Schlüssel bekommen.
Er hat die Wohnung gefunden.
Hier wohnst du jetzt für ein Jahr.
Jetzt muss das neue Zuhause
aber auch noch Katrin gefallen.
Oh!
Oh, hier geht's ja
direkt in die Wohnung.
Wow!
Das ist ja der Wahnsinn.
Wer wohnt denn hier?
Wie viele Personen wohnen denn hier?
Ich muss sagen,
der Stil ist ganz anders als ...
... in der Schweiz.
Aber ... Na ja.
Und Bilder.
Wir werden hier einfach
die Sachen an den Rand schieben.
Dann wird so viel Platz vorhanden
sein, damit Celestine spielen kann.
Dann hat sie ihre Turnhalle.
Wow.
Celestine, schau mal, eine Blume!
Die ist aber hübsch.
- Die ist aber nicht für Celestine.
Die Blume ist für jemand anderes.
- Oh!
Aber Celestine bekommt ein Geschenk.
- Celestine, schau mal!
Lass sie doch mal runter! Oh!
Oh!
Schatz!
Das ist für Gardo Max,
damit er hier rumrollieren kann.
Schon aufgebaut, ich sag' dir.
- Das ist relativ stabil.
Celestine, schau!
- Ah.
Ja, ja. Sofort, sofort.
Ah.
- Ja, Wahnsinn. Los geht's!
Oh! Wow!
Oh!
Der Anfang ist geschafft.
Das ist wichtig für Jonas.
Der Concours diplomatique, die
zweijährige Diplomatenausbildung,
ist auch ein Test für seine Familie.
In der Schweiz musste Katrin
einen guten Job aufgrund
von Jonas' Ausbildung ablehnen.
Beruflich muss jetzt also auch Katrin
ihren Weg finden,
damit Jonas
die Karriere weiterverfolgen kann.
Ich würde gerne Konzerte spielen.
Und vielleicht auch wieder
im Ensemble Musik machen.
Und vielleicht an
der Deutschen Schule unterrichten.
Komm zu Mama!
- Mama.
Möchtest du zu Mama gehen?
Ja, Mama ist heiss.
Zurück in Myanmar.
Alexander reist heute mit seiner
Chefin in die Hauptstadt Naypyidaw.
Sie treffen dort
ein hohes Regierungsmitglied.
Sie wollen von ihm eine Zusicherung,
dass der Vizeaussenminister
an einem Treffen mit Schweizer
Vertretern in Naypyidaw teilnimmt.
Das kaum bewohnte Naypyidaw
ist eigentlich seit 14 Jahren
die Hauptstadt von Myanmar.
Ausser der Regierung
ist jedoch wenig da.
Der Plan ist, dass irgendwann
auch die Botschaften hierherziehen.
Aber momentan
ist man hier ziemlich einsam.
Man weiss nicht,
ob es eine Voraussicht ist,
dass hier irgendwann
wirklich so viel los sein wird.
Oder ob es jetzt einfach mal ...
... ein Prunkbau ist,
diese riesige Strasse.
Das ist ein wenig Gigantismus.
Und jetzt
geht's ans Regierungstreffen.
Das Wichtigste ist,
auf höchstmöglicher Ebene
die Gespräche zu führen,
und die Substanz und die Messages
platzieren zu können.
Alexander soll heute lernen,
wie ein solches Gespräch
mit einem hochrangigen
Regierungsmitglied abläuft.
Mingalaba. How are you? Nice
to see you again. Yes. Excellent.
Thank you very much
for receiving us. Thank you.
We don't need to.
- Maybe two, three or four agendas.
Thank you very much.
Alexander und seine Chefin
sind optimistisch,
dass der Vizeaussenminister
wirklich am Meeting teilnehmen wird.
Es ist noch nicht alles
genau bestätigt,
aber sein Name
ist auf jeden Fall gefallen.
Für uns war v.a. wichtig,
diese Informationen zu bekommen.
Es war ein sehr positives Gespräch.
Vielen Dank dafür.
- Gern geschehen.
Nicht nur Naypyidaw,
sondern auch zu sehen,
wie es mit ihnen funktioniert.
Der Vizeaussenminister
hat übrigens zwei Monate später
wirklich am Treffen mit der Schweiz
teilgenommen.
* Sanfte, monotone Hang-Klänge *
Es geht wieder zurück
in die grösste Stadt, nach Yangon.
Alexander ist für 15 Monate hier.
Bis vor kurzer Zeit konnten
in Myanmar, im früheren Burma,
über 90 % der Menschen
nicht lesen und schreiben.
Ja, okay. Ab ins Leben, komm!
Die Frau eines Arbeitskollegen
zeigt Alexander heute die Stadt.
Das wird z.B. alles verkocht.
In der Regel kommt das alles mit
in den Wok. Das ist total lecker.
Das Auto, wie das über die ...
- Ja, das fährt drüber.
Das ist denen wurst.
Die eiern da drüber.
* Trillerpfeife, Anfeuerungsrufe *
Hello, mingalaba.
- Mingalaba. How are you?
Very good. How are you?
- Very good. - Mingalaba.
Are you going to play football?
No? No, not you.
* Musik, Stimmengewirr *
Eine richtige Streetparty.
Ich finde es mega sympathisch.
Man hat das Gefühl,
die Leute sind sehr spielfreudig.
Es läuft halt viel,
hier und da hat es Musik.
Die Leute sind auf der Strasse.
Mir gefällt's.
Myanmar
ist nicht so prestigeträchtig.
Unter Diplomaten gehört das Land
nicht gerade
zu den Topdestinationen.
Aber es gehört dazu,
auch an solchen Orten zu arbeiten,
wenn man sich, wie jetzt Alexander,
für diesen Berufsweg entschieden hat.
Man muss eben immer und immer wieder
Geduld und Verständnis haben,
dass die anderen
einen nicht verstehen
und das oft nicht einfach ist.
Man kann noch so viele Bücher
über die Kultur lesen -
man muss es doch
selbst erfahren haben.
Damit zurechtzukommen
ist am ersten Tag noch einfach,
aber vielleicht ist es
in drei Monaten ganz anders
und vielleicht fühlt man sich
dann eben auch etwas angegriffen
oder auch müde,
in dieser Kultur zu leben.
* Voluminöse Streicherklänge *
Die Schweiz braucht Diplomaten,
weil die Schweiz das
mit Abstand globalisierteste Land
auf der Welt ist.
Wir sind konstant
in wirtschaftliche, politische,
und sonstige Beziehungen verwickelt,
die konstant geregelt werden müssen.
Das ist eine Frage des Überlebens
für dieses Land,
dass wir das Netz
weltweit unterhalten.
* Leichte Musik *
Senegal war noch vor 60 Jahren
eine französische Kolonie.
Heute gehört es
zu den stabilsten Staaten Afrikas.
Viviane Riviere?
- Oui. - Enchante, Madame.
Jean-Baptiste hat hier mittlerweile
sein Auslandpraktikum begonnen.
Eine eigene Wohnung fehlt noch,
deshalb hat die Botschaft
ein paar Besichtigungstermine
in Dakar für ihn organisiert.
Sinon,
c'est une question de feeling.
Jean-Baptiste werden v.a.
klassische Expat-Wohnungen gezeigt.
* Schwerfällige Musik *
Merci.
Ich frage mich, was ich in so einer
riesigen Wohnung alleine mache?
* Vogelzwitschern,
entfernte Sirenen *
Das Schwimmbad
hat noch nicht so viele Besucher.
* Schwermütige Westernklänge *
Mein Zuhause sind die Leute,
die Menschen.
Hier habe ich noch kein Netzwerk.
Ich kenne noch niemanden.
Jean-Baptiste
hat sich kurz vor der Abreise
von seiner Partnerin getrennt.
Eigentlich wollten sie
gemeinsam nach Senegal ziehen.
Heute, im Januar 2018,
stelle ich mir keine Familie vor.
Wenn es kommt, dann kommt es.
Das ist jetzt kein grosses Thema.
Bewusst nicht?
Bewusst nicht.
An einem ganz anderen Punkt
in der Ausbildung steht Samira.
Sie ist noch immer in der Schweiz.
Vor drei Monaten
kam ihre Tochter Alani zur Welt.
Was bist du am Drucksen?
Was erzählst du da?
Bist du noch ein wenig verschlafen?
Ja?
Wir geniessen es wirklich.
Die zweijährige Diplomatenausbildung
darf Samira für etwas mehr
als fünf Monate unterbrechen.
Aber schon bald
geht es ins Auslandpraktikum
und Samira arbeitet wieder 100 %.
Jetzt fängt es an, dass ich gewisse
Sachen für Kairo organisieren muss.
Jetzt haben wir hoffentlich
eine Wohnung, das ist super.
Auf die Arbeit
freue ich mich eigentlich auch.
Ich hoffe, dass ich der Prüfungs-
situation gerecht werden kann.
Ich denke,
wenn ich wieder am Arbeiten bin ...
Ich hoffe, dass ich mich
wieder konzentrieren kann.
Aber wenn ich weiss,
dass sie in guten Händen ist -
das wird sie sein -,
dann geht das auf jeden Fall.
Komm!
Willst du auf den Rücken liegen?
Machen wir ein wenig Gymnastik
nach dem Aufwachen.
Na? Etwas Gymnastik.
Machen wir Gymnastik!
Uh! Uh! Uh!
* Schnell gezupfte Gitarrenklänge *
Fast 13 Mio. Menschen leben in der
Region Region rund um Buenos Aires.
Viele Menschen hier
haben europäische Wurzeln.
Auf der Residenz
der Schweizer Botschaft
nimmt Jonas heute
an einem Künstler-Lunch teil.
Gemeinsam mit seinem Chef,
dem Botschafter Hanspeter Mock,
feilt er noch an der Tischordnung.
Ist das so,
wie sie es normalerweise hinlegen?
Es ist sogar schöner.
Ein bisschen mehr so ...
... damit es nicht fällt.
Aber es ist gut.
Ich glaube, alles ist in Ordnung.
In diesen Räumen werden
die Interessen der Schweiz vertreten,
in der Residenz
der Schweizer Botschaft.
Nachher möchte ich,
dass er sich richtig vorstellt,
und die Gäste am Tisch,
bevor man mit dem Essen beginnt,
auch im Namen der Botschaft
willkommen heisst.
Gäste begrüssen.
- Hanspeter Mock. - Anne.
Adelia Marten.
- Jonas Belina, freut mich.
Frau Marten, freut mich.
* Schnelle
klassische Gitarrenklänge *
Und dann kommt die erste
Tischrede von Jonas - auf Spanisch.
Ein ganz herzliches Willkommen,
v.a. an die Schweizer Künstler.
Esta es mi machete,
Spickzettel auf Deutsch.
Prost!
Ich glaube, er war gut,
nicht zu lang.
Das ist
eine wichtige Voraussetzung.
Nächstes Mal wäre es noch besser,
wenn er keinen Zettel
in der Hand hätte.
Ein erster Erfolg für Jonas
an seinem neuen Arbeitsort.
Eine kleine Siesta - warum nicht?
* Beschwingte Musik *
Jean-Baptiste besichtigt inzwischen
die dritte Wohnung.
Und die ist es jetzt.
* Stimmengewirr *
Die Aussicht ist Wahnsinn,
das Licht am Abend ist super.
Es ist einfach gemütlicher.
Weisst du, die Farben und so ...
Es hat zwei Zimmer.
Du fühlst dich einfach mehr zu Hause
als in der anderen mit fünf Zimmern.
So ... Wow, riesig!
Bundesrat Johann Schneider-Ammann ist
im Clinch mit den Schweizer Bauern.
Grund ist Schneider-Ammanns
freizügige Haltung
gegenüber dem Freihandel.
Um ein Freihandelsabkommen
ist es in den letzten Tagen gegangen.
Es war ein freundlicher Empfang
im Aussenministerium in Buenos Aires.
Für einen so freundlichen Empfang
des damaligen Wirtschaftsministers
mussten Jonas und seine
Botschaftskolleginnen und -kollegen
viel arbeiten.
Die grösste Herausforderung ist,
dass nichts vergessen geht.
Es ist eine riesige Delegation.
Da muss man verschiedene
parallele Events im Kopf haben.
So ein Bundesratsbesuch ist
ein organisatorisches Grossprojekt.
Jede Minute ist im Ablauf genau
geplant und jedes Wort muss sitzen.
Jonas hat an der Ansprache von Johann
Schneider-Ammann mitgearbeitet.
Es ist natürlich sehr schön,
wenn man
die inhaltliche Vorbereitung macht
und dann Elemente wiedererkennt,
wenn der Speaker die Rede hält.
Das ist wirklich sehr spannend.
Es ist sehr gut gelaufen bis jetzt
und ich bin sicher,
dass es für den Rest
auch noch gut gehen wird.
Es war gut.
- Ja, es war super.
Ich denke, es gab wirklich
einen guten Einblick
in die ökonomische Lage
in Argentinien.
... das gegenseitige Verständnis
erhöhen zu können.
Jonas trägt die Verantwortung dafür,
dass der Bundesrat immer zur
richtigen Zeit am richtigen Ort ist.
Die Idee ist,
dass sich jetzt die Leute,
die viele formelle Treffen hatten,
informell austauschen können.
Es gibt etwas zu essen
und zu trinken.
Es sind sehr gute Gelegenheiten,
um Kontakte knüpfen zu können.
Jonas lernt:
Ein perfekter Gastgeber zu sein,
ist eine ganz wichtige Aufgabe
im diplomatischen Dienst.
Wenn man sieht,
dass sich die Leute wohlfühlen,
vergisst man
die ganze Zeit der Vorbereitung.
Aber ich muss auch sagen:
Solche Anlässe, solche Besuche
kommen nur mit Erfolg zustande,
wenn man auf ein gutes Team
zählen kann.
Glücklicherweise
ist das in Buenos Aires der Fall.
Der Bundesratsbesuch mit 50-köpfiger
Delegation ging gut über die Bühne.
Herr Bundesrat,
bis morgen sehr früh.
Gute Nacht, gute Erholung.
Gute Erholung Ihnen.
- Vielen Dank.
Merci.
* Harmonische Klänge *
* Die Musik verklingt. *
* Gleichförmig monotone Klänge *
Hier wohnt Cristina.
Seit neun Monaten absolviert sie
ihr Auslandpraktikum in New York.
Normalerweise
nehme ich mir die Zeit für mich,
lese noch Zeitung
und trinke in Ruhe meinen Tee.
Aber an einem so grossen,
wichtigen Tag wie heute,
denke ich natürlich
schon seit dem Morgen daran,
was kommt
und was wir alles machen müssen.
Cristina arbeitet in New York
bei der UNO-Mission.
Sie vertritt dort die Schweiz
im sog. Fünften Ausschuss.
Dieser ist fürs Budget
und Management verantwortlich.
Heute muss sie Vertreter ver-
schiedener Länder davon überzeugen,
ein Pilotprojekt zu unterstützen,
für das sich die Schweiz starkmacht.
Die Hälfte der Mitarbeiter
bei der UNO ist Non-Staff
und hat keinen Zugang
zum eigenen, internen Rechtssystem.
Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt
für uns als Schweiz.
Wir finden,
alle, die an der UNO arbeiten -
egal welcher Personalkategorie
sie angehören -
müssen Zugang
zu einem Rechtssystem haben.
In diesem Fall zum Ombudsmann.
Die Idee einer solchen
Beschwerdestelle für UNO-Angestellte
muss Cristina noch
mit der Zentrale in Bern besprechen.
Wie läuft es in Bern?
- Es geht gut. Etwas turbulent.
Bei euch?
- Auch.
Es sieht gut aus.
- Es nimmt langsam Fahrt auf.
Der Fünfte Ausschuss.
Langsam wird es turbulent.
Hat es zu diesem Pilotprojekt
noch Entwicklungen gegeben?
Ich habe heute mehrere Treffen.
- Mit den Briten, oder?
Mit ihnen
haben wir schon gesprochen.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob sich da viel bewegt.
Vielleicht müssen wir
nochmals mit ihnen reden.
Mir ist einfach wichtig,
dass du bei den drei, vier
neuen Paragraphen dazuschreibst,
was rational ist.
Ja.
- Dann sollte das schnell gehen.
Okay, gut.
Wir sehen uns bei den Iren
zum Mittagessen.
(Mann) Ja.
- Ähm ...
Kommst du auch?
- Ich glaube nicht.
Jetzt gilt es ernst am UNO-Hauptsitz.
Cristina muss den Vertretern
der anderen Länder klarmachen,
was der Sinn des Pilotprojekts ist.
Dies - wie so oft in der Diplomatie -
an kurzen sog. informellen Treffen.
Darf ich kurz ... Er ist schon da.
So, thank you so much.
- Thanks. That's okay.
See you.
- See you. - Bye.
Japan ist oft extrem skeptisch.
Das wusste ich von Anfang an.
Aber es ist gut, um zu spüren,
wo sie stehen.
Sie gehören zu
den grossen Beitragszahlern der UNO.
Jetzt ist Israel an der Reihe.
Exactly!
See you soon.
- See you very soon.
Ja, das sind die Mexikaner.
(Englisch) So, 37 ...
This is the questions.
Where is my CBQ report?
These are the ... I have made
copies, too. You have your own?
Bye, Jorge. - See you.
- See you soon.
Thank you.
- No worries.
Bye-bye.
Jetzt werden wir sehen.
Alle müssen mit den eigenen Leuten,
mit der Hauptstadt sprechen.
Ich glaube,
wir sind auf einem guten Weg,
dass wir zusammenarbeiten
und uns unterstützen können.
Ich bin zufrieden.
* Eindringliche Streicherklänge *
* Eindringliche,
orientalische Klänge *
Alani.
Oh!
Ja. Bist du auf dem Rücken?
Samira ist mittlerweile
in Kairo angekommen.
Ihre Ausbildung geht weiter.
Ih, diesen Backofen
haben sie gar nicht geputzt.
Unglaublich!
Ih.
Krass.
Na, ein bisschen
mit dir spielen und schmusen.
Samiras Mutter Erika
ist vor zwei Tagen angekommen.
Sie will
die junge Familie unterstützen,
wenn Samira ab morgen
wieder 100 % arbeitet.
Es ist natürlich schon
eine extreme Umstellung.
Vorher waren wir eigentlich
jeden Tag 24 Std. zusammen,
jetzt bin ich den ganzen Tag weg.
Das ist schon hart.
Auch für sie, denke ich.
Sie ist sich gewöhnt,
dass wir immer zusammen sind.
Und das hoffe ich halt ...
gell ...
... ja, gell,
dass es auch dir gut geht.
* Kreischen *
- Ja.
Edgar kann in Kairo noch ein paar
seiner Projekt weiter betreuen.
Aber v.a. übernimmt er jetzt
die Hauptverantwortung zu Hause.
(Erika) Ca aussi? Oh, c'est froid.
Ich bin jetzt
für knapp drei Wochen hier.
Ich habe aber im Sinn, sicherlich
noch öfter zu kommen, auch länger.
Na, du bist in besten Händen
bei Papa und bei Oma.
* Gemächliche Soulmusik *
* Hupen *
Cristina bespricht das Pilotprojekt
zur Beschwerdestelle an der UNO
jetzt mit ihrer Chefin.
Ein gutes Feedback ist wichtig.
Es zählt, wenn Cristina die
Diplomatenausbildung bestehen will.
Das Pilotprojekt wäre Teil
des internen Justizsystems AOJ.
Hallo Alexandra. Kann ich kurz
AOJ mit dir besprechen?
Ja, setz dich!
Voila.
Warte, ich nehmen mein Dossier.
Wo stehen wir? - Der Brief ist
seit gestern im Sechsten Ausschuss.
Unter silence procedure.
Wie es aussieht,
ist jetzt der Paragraph so drin,
wie wir ihn gerne hätten.
Sie haben es tatsächlich geschafft.
- Ja. - Gut, schön.
Wenn wir die Antworten haben,
schickst du das nach Bern,
damit sie es konsultieren können.
- Genau.
Jetzt, da sie in meinem Team,
im Finanz- und Managementausschuss
verhandelt,
ist es meines Erachtens
so etwas wie die Kür.
und das macht sie sehr gut.
So fein.
Sie ist eine gute Ergänzung
für mein bisheriges Team.
Frag doch beim Sekretariat,
ob es etwas gibt,
das noch etwas weniger alt ist.
- Okay.
Super.
Vielen Dank.
Heute Abend muss Alani zum ersten Mal
ohne Samira einschlafen.
* Eindringliche,
orientalische Klänge *
Samira hat nämlich
ihren ersten offiziellen Termin:
die 1.-August-Feier in Kairo.
On y va?
- Oui.
Zu Hause
schaut Mutter Erika zu Alani.
* Schwungvolle orientalische Musik *
Ich freue mich schon,
das ist jetzt schon ein Event.
Thank you. Shukran.
Was nach Vergnügen aussieht,
ist immer auch Arbeit.
Für Diplomaten geht es
an solchen Anlässen ums Netzwerken.
It's over there?
- It's over there.
Hallo.
- Hallo, guten Abend.
How is it going?
- Good to see you.
Der stellvertretende Missionschef
Adrian Hauri
ist ab morgen Samiras Chef.
Er muss ihre Arbeit beurteilen.
Go ahead!
Doch dann gibt es ein Problem.
Oder willst du ihr
noch die Flasche geben?
Nicht? Das hast du schon versucht?
Ja.
Also.
Sonst rufst du mich wieder an? Okay?
Mais c'est une question d'habitude.
Geht's nicht? Oh, ich höre sie.
Also. Ach.
Also ich komme zurück. Ich komme
nachher vielleicht nochmals.
Unsere Tochter
ist total am Durchdrehen,
meine Mutter ist mit ihr zu Hause.
- Ach, ist sie ...
Ich muss kurz zurück.
Ich komme nachher wieder.
Es tut mir sehr leid,
aber sie ist total panisch.
Es tut mir sehr leid, aber abends
ist sie es noch nicht gewohnt.
Ja, noch 4 ... 3 Min.
Das ist gut, er kommt.
* Hupen *
Is it this one?
* Der Fahrer spricht arabisch. *
Yeah, yeah.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
* Eindringliche
elektronische Klänge *
Wenn du nicht morgen
deinen ersten Tag hättest,
hätte ich es durchgezogen.
Aber so dachte ich ...
Ja, ja, ich habe es ja gehört.
* Sie flüstern unverständlich. *
* Alani weint. *
(Alle) Ja.
Komm, wir gehen stillen.
Der Start zurück in die Diplomatie
ist nicht gelungen.
In 10 Std.
beginnt Samira ihre Ausbildung
auf der Botschaft in Kairo.
Kann sie diese bestehen?
Dies sehen Sie in der der nächsten
Folge "Die jungen Diplomaten".